ازمه الاكسلانس ورساله الامام سجال طريف
بين ياسمين عبد العزيز ورضوى الشربيني
وساخن بين مؤلف ومخرج النار بالنار الهرشه
السابعه ابرز الافضل وسلطان الطرب يغير
نبرته تجاه اصاله اليكم الابرز الاسبوع
الماضي
[موسيقى]
في اول اطلاله اعلاميه له بعد رحيل ابنه
وديع اكد سلطان الطرب جورج وسوف انه لن
يعتزل الغناء حتى اخر نفس وبدا لافتا خلال
اطلالته في برنامج مراحل معالي العلياني
تغير نبره الوسوف تجاه اصاله التي وصفها
بالعظيمه واوضح ما حدث خلال ليله تريونايت
راس السنه في الرياض مؤكدا انه لم يقابلها
وجها لوجه ولو حدث ذلك لسلم عليها وفي
نبره اكثر تصالحيه قال جورج وسوف انه كان
قاسيا عليها قليلا لكنها بالمقابل كانت
معه بمنتهى اللطف
وبكل احساس حلو هذا صغير ابوي
واعادت اصاله تغريد هذا المقطع وعلقت عليه
بالقول شكرا يا حبيب حبيبي الله يحفظك
ويطول بعمرك ويرحم صديقك ابي
[موسيقى]
وفي اصداء موسم العرض الرمضاني واجه مسلسل
رساله الامام عده انتقادات الاسبوع الماضي
على منصات التواصل خاصه بعدما فجر الشاعر
السوري حذيفه العرجي مفاجاه صادمه حينما
كشف ان الفنان خالد النبوي الذي يجسد دور
الشافعي
ظهر في مقطع من المسلسل منشدا بيتين من
الشعر رسبا في العمل الى الامام لكنهما من
اوائل ما كتب العرج قبل عشر سنوات حسب ما
قال في تدوينه نشرها عبر حسابه الرسمي على
فيسبوك واعلن لاحقا سعيه لرفع دعوى تعويض
عن حقوقه الادبيه والنفسيه في المحكمه
الاقتصاديه المصريه ضد صناع مسلسل رساله
الامام
[موسيقى]
انهي خلقه دي وهي دي خلقه كما واجه الفنان
المصري محمد سعد موجه من الانتقادات
الاسبوع الماضي بسبب فيديو تم تسريبه من
كواليس تصوير مسلسل اكسلانس بدا فيه سعد
بحاله غضب شديد في موقع التصوير وقيل انه
وجه شتائم تهين بعض افراد فريق العمل ونشر
محمد سعد عبر حسابه الرسمي على موقع
فيسبوك فيديو للشجار وتوجه لجمهوره موضحا
بانما يشاهدونه في الفيديو جزء مما كان
يحصل يوميا وانه توجب عليه التدخل لفض
الخناقه بحسب تعبيره متوجها بالشكر لاهالي
منطقه الحرفيين التي كان يتم فيها التصوير
بدوره اوضح مخرج العمل ابرام نشات انه ليس
المقصود بالشجار او اي من فريق العمل
وانما شخصان كان يفترض ان يسيطر على
الموقع وحصلت المشاده نتيجه عدم السيطره
على الشارع وتعطيل حركه التصوير لمده
ساعات بحسب قوله انا اعتذر انا
[موسيقى]
اسف
قلت ادخل سيجان اخر حول ترتيب اسماء مسلسل
جعفر العمده تسببت فيه اطلاله اعلاميه
لمنه فضالي حينما قالت انها فوجئت بكتابه
اسم الممثل احمد داش قبلها وقبل زميلات
لها في العمل باعتباره اصغر منهن سنا
وشارك داش المقطع الذي تضمن تصريحات فضالي
وعلق عليه قائلا تحياتي للي كنت فاكرهم
اخواتي
[موسيقى]
وتفاعل متابعون نجم المصريه ياسمين عبد
العزيز على منصات التواصل مع السجال
الطريف بينها وبين رضوى الشربيني حول
احداث مسلسل ضرب نار وتطورات علاقه مهره
بجابل هذه العلاقه التي سرعان ما تعرضت
للخطر بعد وقت قصير من زفافهما
وكان مسلسل الهرش سبعه من ابرز ما تصدر
تفضيلات الجمهور على منصات التواصل
الاسبوع الماضي لوقعيه الحكايه والحوارات
والاداء في عمل يتناول حياه ثنائي على مدى
سنوات من الحب الى الارتباط مرورا
بالخيبات بانتظار المولود الاول والصعوبات
الاقتصاديه التي تتزامن مع مفاجات غير
متوقعه دائما وتحديات تحقيق الذات مع
الانشغال بالاولويات العائليه الاحكام
المسبقه ومدى هشاشه الحب امام الاختبارات
القاسيه
هلا اول شيء مو نحن اجيناكم بكيفنا انتوا
اللي بعدتوا ورانا وثاني شيء لولانا كنتو
هبرتوا بعض ومن المشاهد التي حققت تفاعلا
كبيرا الاسبوع الماضي مشهد يركز الضوء على
العلاقه الشائكه بين السوريين واللبنانيين
والتي يتناولها مسلسل النار بالنار بطريقه
جريئه وربما غير مسبوقه وهو من المسلسلات
التي ستعاد بالكامل خلال النصف الثاني من
رمضان فيما لا يزال السجال مستمرا بين
مؤلف المسلسل رامي كوسا ومخرجه محمد عبد
العزيز حيث يتهم الاول الثاني باجراء
تعديلات غير مبرره على النص دون الرجوع
اليه ومنها تبرير خلع مريم لحجابها من اجل
فوز بجواز سفر لبناني وكذلك تستمر
المواجهات الساخنه في مسلسل واخيرا وسط
انقسام متابعيه بين معجبين بما تقدمه
نادين جيم من اكشن ومنتقدين يرون في ذلك
جرعه زائده على حساب تقدم الحكايه